bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous cette arrivée en direct vous
êtes sénateur de la Côte d'Or président
du groupe RDPI Renaissance au Sénat
c'est le groupe des sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour François Patriat
bonjour on va parler de cette rentrée
parlementaire sous tension François
Patriat et on va commencer par ce qui
s'est passé hier au Sénat le sénateurs
qui ont interpellé le gouvernement sur
le cas Eric Dupont-Moretti alors c'est
la première fois qu'un garde des Sceaux
est renvoyé devant la Cour de Justice de
la République est-ce qu'il peut rester
en poste alors qu'Emmanuel Macron disait
lui-même en 2017 qu'une personne mise en
examen devait quitter le gouvernement je
crois qu'il faut revenir sur cette règle
non pas parce que c'est le cas de type
Moretti mais parce que
la situation sont très différentes en
l'occurrence j'entends bien que quand il
y a des CAF flagrants des délifs
flagrants tomaticité s'installe mais
quand il s'agit de en répétition de
marronniers de dossiers qui dure pendant
des années sans que moi je ne connaisse
que je ne connais pas les tenants et les
aboutissants des dossiers concernant
Eric du pommeretti avec qui je me suis
entretenu avant-hier hier j'étais à côté
de lui au Sénat et on évoque
éventuellement que les procédures qu'il
a respecté sont des prostituées
totalement légales et quand il dit
simplement qu'il n'a pas pris les
conseils mais il a écouté ce que disait
les conseillers en l'occurrence et que
le disait que absolument il n'avait
commis aucun délit vous trouvez que la
situation par exemple de François Bayrou
en 2017 et celle d'Eric Dupont aurait-il
aujourd'hui sont très différentes
complètement différentes complètement
différente d'ailleurs je déplore la
faire François Bayrou 2017 on est en
le feuilleton dur toujours n'est pas
réglé
personne mise en examen devait quitter
le gouvernement vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ça
on a vu les affaires qui ont fleuri
celles qui sont lui-même
ma position aujourd'hui c'est que le
Eric Dupond-Moretti et le garde des
sceaux et pleinement dans sa tâche qu'il
a fait les étages d'une roule la justice
qu'il a un texte très important la
réforme de la justice qui est matérielle
au printemps 2023 que ce texte il est
aujourd'hui athlétique ce texte va faire
vraiment avancer les choses dans un sens
que souhaitent les Français que la
justice aujourd'hui et que l'empêcher
aujourd'hui te poursuivre son travail
pour des on verra bien le dossier
Dupond-Moretti il reviendra sur la table
dans un an compte tenu de la pénocation
dans un an on en reviendra pour qu'au
bout du compte ça fasse chute François
je considère à titre personnel qu'il y a
la règlement de compte avec les
magistrats les juges que voilà c'est une
histoire qui à mon avis on va pas
perturber le fonctionnement des réformes
importantes pour ce pays parce qu'il y
aurait un sujet qui à mes yeux ne
parlent n'est pas abouti enfin ça va
trier il a un poste stratégique
aujourd'hui Eric Dupond-Moretti au
gouvernement il est garde des sous vous
venez de le dire dans le cadre de ces
fonctions il sera même peut-être amené à
nommer le prochain procureur général
auprès de la Cour de cassation qui
pourrait être son accusateur dans cette
affaire est-ce qu'il y a pas un problème
de de conflits d'intérêt encore une fois
je ne pense pas moi
Éric dupaumoretti
paradoxalement est parfaitement aimé par
les Français moi quand j'entends quand
j'entends les Français le territoire
tous les week-ends
aujourd'hui les Français dire qu'ils
sont choqués ils disent voilà ça fait
partie des bulletins quotidiens
médiatique et l'affaire du pont Moretti
à mon avis on va en parlera pendant 3
jours
et après il pourra rester serein à sa
tâche vous avez entendu le groupe
socialiste au Sénat au début puisque
Eric Dupont-Moretti était au Sénat
puisqu'il y avait un débat sur les états
généraux
vous avez entendu jean-Pierre Sueur qui
parlait au nom du groupe socialiste et
Nathan socialiste et qui demande à
Elisabeth borne de venir s'expliquer sur
le maintien en fonction d'Eric
dupont-morythié est-ce qu'elle doit
venir pour vous est-ce qu'elle doit en
parler par exemple cet après-midi aux
questions d'actualité moi je poserai une
question d'actualité aujourd'hui c'est
pas sur ces sujets secondaires que je
vais les poser je pense que les sujets
qui intéressent les Français ce sont pas
ce genre de sujet Jean-Pierre sur que je
connais qui est un ami par ailleurs si
riche en censeur au nom d'un parti et
d'un groupe qui aujourd'hui souhaite la
démission de tout le gouvernement et la
chute du gouvernement il est peut-être
dans son rôle je ne pense pas démocratie
moi de aujourd'hui je pose une question
non pas sur l'affaire Dupond-Moretti ou
sur l'affaire entre Monsieur katnas et
Madame Rousseau je poserai une question
sur l'énergie ce qui intéresse les
Français aujourd'hui c'est l'énergie
sont secondaires et moi je regrette
qu'on fasse des questions d'actualité
des questions de querelle inutiles qui
ont fin de compte retarde les réforme de
la France ne sont pas prioritaire mais
justement ces sujets secondaires est-ce
qu'ils occultent pas à les sujets
majeurs et est-ce que un départ dérive
Dupont-Moretti et d'Alexis colère ne
permettrait pas d'assainir un petit peu
l'ambiance qui est déjà suffisamment
électrique sur des sujets de fonds comme
les retraites comme la collection
chômage comme l'énergie que vous citiez
est-ce que compte les dans un état de
droit et qui est la séparation des
pouvoirs on ne peut pas laisser faire la
justice enquêter la justice l'affaire
sereinement
s'en servir en permanence contre bien
mais l'opposition aujourd'hui ne donne
pas un spectacle suffisamment clair et
attractif donc on puisse s'arrêter à
cela le spectacle on a vu cette nuit à
l'Assemblée nationale
désespérant dérisoires monsieur on voit
bien le sur quoi porte les sujets
aujourd'hui on oculte l'essentiel je
vous rappelle que la France est pour
vous de l'assurance chômage en tout cas
la partie la mesure phare de du texte je
pense que je pense que l'assurance
chômage le texte de loi va passer je
pense que la lothmie va passer je pense
qu'il y a certains nombre de textes et
non des moines sont des effets
importants j'étais hier en commission
cela l'opening en commission de la
défense une formation du ministère de
manière voilà des fois des sujets qui va
revenir à ces sujets mais c'est le sujet
de la sécurité alors faire du sujet
Eric Dupond-Moretti monsieur catenas
maintenant des sujets je trouve que ce
sont des sujets j'allais dire de l'écume
des choses de l'écume des choses
vous êtes sur cette ligne vous dites
c'est des sujets secondaires c'est ce
que vous dites il faut pas en parler
c'est l'écume des choses bon hier Aurore
berger qui est votre homologue à
l'Assemblée nationale le président du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale c'était sa question elle a
attaqué de manière implicite Adrien
catenin se provoquant un tollé du côté
de la nuit pelle aurait pas dû faire ça
alors elle est dans le contexte de
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui on ne
parle toute seule le débat politique
aujourd'hui
ce tourne je désespéré entre 11000
Rousseau et katnas est-ce que vous
pensez que quand on a en face de nous la
guerre les épidémies l'inflation
de l'écologie l'écologie les sujets
qu'on doit aborder sont ces sujets là
pour vous donc
elle est dans le contexte de l'Assemblée
où elle voit bien que le gouvernement
était attaqué sur ces sujets et que elle
essaye de montrer aux oppositions ce
qu'il ferait mieux de regarder la poutre
qu'ils ont dans l'oeil plutôt que la
paille qui a dans le nôtre
vous dénoncez une ambiance un peu
délétère à l'Assemblée nationale
vous-même la majorité vous avez déposé
et vous allez déposer des textes
relativement clivant l'assurance chômage
en est un mais le budget est
l'éventuelle réforme des retraites le
débat qui s'annonce sur l'immigration
est-ce que par ces textes clivant la
majorité contribue pas à cette ambiance
un peu électrique dans l'hémicycle des
accords
justement est courage parce qu'il prend
les vrais sujets de ce pays le sujet du
travail
quand on a un département regardez
aujourd'hui comme la Sarthe c'est un
ministre qui me le disait hier il y a 30
000 offres d'emploi
plus que de nombre de chômeurs de
catégories A est-ce qu'il faut pas
s'interroger à ce sujet aujourd'hui la
France ne retrouvera la voie du progrès
du redressement que par le travail c'est
vrai pour le retraite c'est vrai pour
l'assurance chômage donc le gouvernement
loin d'évacuer les sujets difficiles
prends ce début de quinquennat les
sujets difficiles il prend l'immigration
il prend l'assurance chômage il prend
les retraites il prend les sujets
concertés comme le président l'avait
pourtant produit sur le travail sur
l'immigration sur les retraites la
concertation est limitée la concertation
le texte de loi sur l'assurance chômage
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
il fait en sorte que la convention
actuelle puisse durer et puis dans le
même temps il ouvre une conversation il
ouvre il ouvre avec les partenaires
sociaux une concertation qui aboutira à
la méthode qui sera retenue au bout pour
faire en sorte que l'assurance chômage
fonctionne mieux dans le temps que c'est
plus facile autant que c'est plus
difficile donc la concertation elle est
ouverte la concertation sur les
retraites elle dure depuis quatre ans
cet après-midi le chef de l'État a
tranché depuis la semaine dernière pour
le fait que le gouvernement ne passait
pas en force et qu'il allait rouvrir sur
les sujets les plus importants sur les
carrières longues les carrières pénibles
sur les carrières hachées sur notre
emploi des seniors sur les sujets
importants auxquels tiennent les
syndicats monsieur berger tient lui-même
et bien on puisse en discuter pour
aboutir on espère un texte qui sera
cranté à Noël
il y a des concertations qui souffrent
sur quel point vous vous êtes prêts au
compromis moi je pense aujourd'hui je
même le président l'archet l'a dit qu'il
faille une réforme des retraites on peut
me dire aujourd'hui ce que dit le
coronaire presque dit le corps des
terrains il y a des difficultés pour
notre
retraite par répartition il y a
aujourd'hui des moyens qui sont qui font
retrouver de la l'autonomie budgétaire
pour pouvoir avancer sur des sujets
comme la fin de vie sur des sujets comme
l'autonomie
des deux côtés sinon c'est sinon c'est
pas une concertation sur quel point vous
êtes prêt à faire des compromis
qu'à partir du moment où on voulait pas
augmenter les cotisations ou on ne
voulait pas baisser les potions le seul
critère comme sur lequel on peut jouer
c'est le critère d'âge expliquez-moi
mesdames comment la France serait un
îlot d'aisance de bonheur
Nirvana ou seuls les Français pourraient
travailler jusqu'à 60 ans alors que
l'ensemble des pays autour de nous ont
travaillé 65 à 67 ans et qu'en Suisse
une votation vient de déterminer que
je crois que le gouvernement donne
l'exemple aujourd'hui en disant dans le
dans la sphère publique
on doit aujourd'hui prendre des mesures
en matière de la dire de comportement
je crois que le gouvernement a dit qu'il
prenait toutes les mesures pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de pénurie il peut y avoir
des tensions sur l'électricité qui
doivent être partagées puisque les
réacteur nucléaire doit être le plus
vite possible remis en route donc il est
bien normal d'appeler les Français à la
responsabilité quand le président parler
d'abondance on a eu l'abondance
d'énergie on a eu du pétrole pas cher on
a eu des gasoil pas cher on a eu du bois
pas cher on a eu des produits pas chers
ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui dans le
même temps c'est appeler les gens à ne
pas faire de la spéculation sur la
pénurie je pense en particulier on pèler
de bois qui coûtait très peu cher du
temps qui ont déjà triplé devant tu dois
toujours dire qu'il y aura une carence
alors ce sont des sous-produits des
sueurs de bois côté va bien qu'il y en a
partout j'en connais chez moi en
Bourgogne en particulier on fait la
pénurie pour pouvoir les vendre plus
cher au mois de novembre donc quand vous
sobriété
donc je pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut un
appel à la responsabilité que tout le
monde en tienne compte mais que nos
comportements quotidiens je crois que
les Français dans leur comportement
quotidien maintenant il y a un
changement je le vois dans l'utilisation
de l'eau dans l'ouverture du chauffage
dans le règlement de la température dans
les dans les je vous avais partir dans
mon bureau depuis 4 jours il fait 15
degrés bon alors que le chauffage au
Sénat alors le Sénat donne l'exemple
pour une fois c'est pas si mal d'aller
il y a évidemment des aides pour les
ménages qui sont prévus dans le budget
mais la question se pose aussi des aides
aux collectivité vous avez été président
de région ou François Patriat c'est un
sujet que vous connaissez bien est-ce
qu'il faut des aides supplémentaires
pour les collectivités pour les aider à
faire face à cette hausse des prix de
l'énergie alors j'entends aujourd'hui le
message des mères
il y a des choses incontournables et il
y a aussi des solutions qu'on peut
évoquer d'abord le gouvernement a fait
un effort d'un milliard d'euros
pratiquement au mois de août lorsque
nous avons voté dans le PLF des mesures
spécifiques pour les collectivités le
gouvernement fait déjà des mesures pour
en fait que les communes 30 000 communes
en France de moins de 1000 habitants
puissent bénéficier du tarif réglementé
ensuite il y a des mesures qui sont
prises sur la TVA différenciée donc le
gouvernement a déjà fait des choses pour
les collectivités
les communes évoquent aussi le problème
de la hausse de l'indice je pourrais
vous rappeler que dans l'histoire de la
République jamais jamais l'État n'a
compensé l'indice jamais jamais jamais
le gouvernement
a décidé d'augmenter le pendant 10 des
fonctionnaires et pour les fonds de la
fonction publique territoriale ce sont
les collectivités qui payent toujours
réactualisé mais jamais l'état de la
compensé
aujourd'hui le débat va s'instaurer à
s'instaurer avec une demande forte
parfois même poujadiste des
collectivités j'entends j'entends mais
oui parce qu'on voit bien que on voit
bien que je vous donne des exemples
j'entende aujourd'hui des mères qui
disent les
recettes ont diminué
ce gouvernement n'a pas baissé la DGF
contrairement à ce qu'ils se disent
depuis 6 ans
il a compensé à l'euro à l'euro attendez
bien
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
bon mais là vous entendez
la hausse des prix de l'énergie ça grève
notre budget est-ce qu'il faut les aider
un peu plus là dessus aujourd'hui
écoutez on débattre je ne sais pas si au
bout du compte l'état aujourd'hui
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
regarde l'état des collectivités locales
je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent les
collectivités locales sont riches elles
ont des moyens elles ont des droits de
mutation qui augmentaient formidablement
pour le département elles ont 11 elles
ont elles ont monté la taxe foncière
parce qu'elles en ont le droit avec
l'inflation elles peuvent le monter
automatiquement notamment de 6%, cette
année elles ont dit que l'augmentation
de la taxe foncière était due à ce que
le gouvernement leur donnait moi ce qui
est faux donc moi je veux qu'il y ait
une part de transparence de vérité
d'honnêteté de leur part je ne doute pas
que certaines communes sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui mais la menace
fermer des écoles de fermer des gymnases
de fermer des piscines aujourd'hui je
pense qu'à l'intérieur des communes il y
a des choix budgétaires à faire elle
menacent aussi de dire que
l'investissement va diminuer le dialogue
se fait avec les communes mais il se
fait aujourd'hui je le vois sur le
territoire je vois ici des élus
nationaux les responsables des
présidents d'assemblées allez exciter
les mères sur le territoire les autres
un petit peu la responsabilité j'ai été
maire nombreuses années
l'assemblée il y a un article dans il y
a un article dans le budget qui prévoit
un dispositif de limitation des dépenses
des collectivités bon est-ce que ça
c'est un article que vous souhaitez
maintenir ou est-ce que c'est un article
que vous allez rejeter ici sur ce texte
là qui est celui de qui était obsédé un
peu qui ressemble aux accords de Cahors
va amender les choses en disant que
peut-être sur ce texte de hausse des
dépenses on va pouvoir on va on va les
limiter on va on va le diminuer je pense
qu'il y aura une avancée une avancée
dans ce sens-là mais enfin les communes
peuvent pas toujours dire tous les jours
j'étais hier j'étais hier en commission
le gouvernement va créer de gendarmerie
tout le monde dit qu'il faut le présent
sur le terrain il y aura 15 milliards
pour la défense et j'entends des
communes qui aujourd'hui mais si on met
des gendarmerie ça va nous coûter cher
pour savoir ce qu'on veut est-ce qu'on
veut des gendarmes on peut pas on peut
pas voir ce double jeu demander plus de
moyens plus de gendarmes et d'en dire
alors que dans la plupart des cas c'est
le département est construit des
gendarmerie donc ce discours ce discours
revendicatif j'étais président de Région
j'allais entendu il y a des problèmes
n'est pas le même pour toutes les
collectivités il y a des régions qui
aujourd'hui ont un milliard un milliard
aujourd'hui département de recettes de
TVA en plus je pense qu'avec la TV
aujourd'hui il y a des aides sont mais
faut bien comprendre avouer comme moi
que l'État ne pourra jamais tout
compenser un mot sur le budget parce
qu'il a été rejeté hier par les députés
en commission on le précise c'est un
coup dur quand même pour la majorité
le républicain ils ont dit qu'il
voterait pas le budget mais qui voterait
qui voterait la censure je crois que de
faut se préparer aujourd'hui voilà
pas le budget donc on sait très bien que
si votre alors ça dépendra est-ce qu'ils
s'absème je sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait
hier ou est-ce qu'ils ont voté contre
ils ont voté contre donc ils ont voté
contre le budget bon pour voter contre
le budget il y a une arme qui est tout à
fait légale que prévoit la Constitution
qui est le 49-3 est-ce que ça veut dire
que sur le budget vous n'avez pas
suffisamment concerté et discuter avec
les oppositions je crois que
ça fait plusieurs fois que madame la
Première ministre et que les ministres
en charge des collectivités reçoivent
l'opposition il reçoivent depuis le
début de l'été
borne recevra la semaine prochaine à
nouveau une volonté tous les présidents
mercredi jeudi donc la concertation elle
se fait il y a des positions de principe
il y a des positions politiques il y a
ceux dont l'objectif n'est pas le
redressement de la France
n'est pas le redressement de nos comptes
n'est pas c'est pas les réformes qui
font avancer ce pays mais qui est leur
seul principe c'est de faire tomber le
gouvernement
s'allumerica j'ai vu des vers j'ai vu
des communistes c'est le seul principe
aujourd'hui bon est-ce que dans ce
contexte là une dissolution n'est pas
inévitable je pense qu'il faut avant de
faire une dissolution
dont je ne sais pas si elle est
inévitable ou pas je sais qu'il faut
faire la preuve que le que le débat
parlementaire est en train de dégénérer
et que la fonction ne veut pas être
assurée tant que le temps que les règles
de la République permettent de
fonctionner le 49-3 il est fait pour ça
vous savez j'étais déjà
je pense que si effectivement sur le
budget
l'opposition unie de votre pas le budget
je pense qu'il aura 49-3 il y aura
plusieurs il y aura plusieurs 49-3
j'essaie de discuter avec les
républicains d'ailleurs des situations
différentes regardez j'ai cru comprendre
j'ai pris des comprendre que ce qui est
sur l'assurance chômage
je suis pas sûr que la droite le vote la
républicain le vote à l'assemblée je
pense qu'il le photon c'est énorme je
pense que sur les routes
que vous avez remarqué que les
République sont allés en ordre dispersé
à Matignon monsieur marlex n'est pas
allé avec Monsieur Retailleau sont allés
différents CE je veux dire qu'ils ont
des attitudes différentes peut-être plus
responsables au Sénat peut-être plus
responsable moi monsieur marlek c'est
tiraillé entre ces troupes qui elles et
sont en plus en période électorale et je
pense que les choix des républicains se
font plus en fonction de leur contexte
électoral que de l'intérêt de ce pays et
je le déploie alors c'est vous aussi à
des tiraillements Aurore bergers votre
homologue à l'Assemblée nationale et
déposer un amendement pour plafonner les
droits de succession elle a pas été
suivie par une partie de son groupe quel
est votre position vous là dessus je
pense que dans ce débat Robert est posé
cet amendement seul bien
des efforts aux Français et on va
demander des efforts aux Français et où
je pense qu'ils connaissent la situation
dramatique que je connaisse les pays
d'Europe et la France en particulier et
que l'époque va plutôt vers des efforts
que vers des largesses
qu'à ce moment-là essayez de dire qu'on
allait faire c'est un engagement du chef
de l'État j'espère qu'on le tiendra j'y
suis favorable j'ai voté pour mais je
pense que le moment n'est pas choisi
aujourd'hui
dirait Aurore berger c'est pas le moment
aujourd'hui de dire on va faire un
cadeau à ceux qui sont les équipes
blessés des patrimoines plutôt que
demander aux Français de payer plus cher
leur panier quotidien donc voilà je
crois que ma position c'est que oui j'y
suis favorable oui je pense je pense que
le gouvernement a raison d'alléger les
impôts je pense qu'il a raison de le
faire que ce soit les impôts de
production que ce soit les impôts sur le
ménage et il le fait il y a déjà dans ce
budget 4 milliards et demi d’allègement
d'impôts 4 milliards et demi d’alégement
d'impôts c'est sans précédent tenants à
cela et n'allons pas trop loin à moi sur
l'immigration oui autre sujet clivant
qui va arriver vraisemblablement en
débat à l'Assemblée puis au Sénat
l'immigration avant un projet de loi à
la fin de l'année a annoncé le chef de
l'État
il a lancé quelques pistes et notamment
celle de
sortir les étrangers dans les zones
soudances en France qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette proposition alors
d'abord pas les étrangers il s'agit les
gens qui nous vaut les gens qui sont
assis pas si tu veux régulière il s'agit
des gens qui sont des nouveaux
immigrants qui arrivent sont traités
comme tel
prix comme cela je peux je peux
l'entendre et je comprends que faire des
univers concentrationnels en région
parisienne où on voit ce qui s'est passé
cette nuit où il faut sortir du crack
etc la chance la France a la chance
d'avoir un espace j'entends bien
j'entends bien que les populations
rurales ils sont réticentes je vais vous
donner un exemple dans la commune où
j'habite puis en Auxois 1600 habitants
ont installé un cada avec dedans 60 ans
60 ans qui arrivent des cornes de
l'Afrique on les a installés là c'est
osé partir de ce processus qui veut que
le chef de l'État aujourd'hui
je peux vous dire que deux ans après je
n'ai pas vu de soucis majeur de la
commune aujourd'hui ces enfants vont à
l'école aujourd'hui la population
l'accepte il y a des gens qui sont
bénévoles pour les accompagner je crois
que ça nécessite un travail en amont
est-ce que c'est un travail en amont en
amont le retour de la présidence des
villes des métropoles contre
celle des zones rurales moi je suis
j'habite Paris mais parfois la campagne
me manque donc je pense que la campagne
est un espace de proximité de qualité
qu'il peut être utilisé pour les
activités économiques pour les activités
touristiques pour les activités
résidentielles et peut-être aussi
utilisé pour faire en sorte mieux
d'accueillir de répartir la population
de notre pays et je suis de ceux qui
pensent que le commis le covid a révélé
l'attractivité des territoires ruraux en
matière de maison aujourd'hui et que
demain l'espace de la campagne attirera
non seulement les familles que
évoquaient mais quel attira les
activités économiques je vois ce
renversement se faire je souhaite qu'il
avance François Patriot dans un an on
lieu crématorial on imagine que vous
travaillez déjà dessus est-ce qu'il y
aura des candidatures communes aux trois
entités de la majorité ou est-ce que ce
sera chacun de son côté et est-ce que
une éventuelle fusion de groupe est
envisageable puisqu'à l'heure actuelle
il y a votre groupe Renaissance et puis
un groupe avec dessinateurs horizons la
fusion des groupes je n'y pense pas
parce qu'il y a un certain confort au
Sénat à vivre dans un groupe où on peut
s'exprimer où on peut voter où on ne
s'en sentirait pas alors ce n'est pas le
cas en brigadé je verrai demain nous
verrons demain même pas aujourd'hui
le responsable du mouvement sur les
élections ce que je souhaite c'est que
dans ce domaine les choses elles
veillent vite et dans la clarté il
s'agit de s'entendre avec nos
partenaires pour faire en sorte que les
sièges entre nos trois composantes
soient répartis en fonction des sortants
et de factions équitables maintenant que
la
majorité s'élargisse au-delà je crois
qu'il y a des cicentrices centristes
aujourd'hui qui soutiennent le président
qui ont signé pour le président qui
demain aux vocations a rejoint la
majorité plutôt dans les votes et les
attitudes que dans les groupes donc
l'évolution des groupes je la vois
beaucoup plus difficile l'évolution des
mentalités qu'on ne se voit le nombre de
parlementaires qui ont signé pour le
Président je pense qu'il y a une marge
qui a une marge pour pouvoir progresser
dans ce sens je crois que la majorité
qui soutient le président s'étendra
s'étendra à travers un peu tous les
groupes qui sont partenaires je crois
qu'avec les groupes qui sont partenaires
aujourd'hui il y a une parfaite qui a
parfaite climat de discussion et que
nous pouvons avancer vite
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin une
interpellation elle a une de la dépêche
politique soyons sérieux c'est la Une de
votre
journal merci Christelle et merci
François Patriat bonne journée on passe
au club des territoires merci
[Musique]